LAURA INGRAHAM TAKES IT AWAY.
>> Laura: SEAN, THANK YOU SO
MUCH.
FANTASTIC TRIBUTE.
I'M LAURA INGRAHAM.
THIS IS "THE INGRAHAM ANGLE."
AS SEAN JUST MENTIONED, OUR
HEARTS ARE HEAVY HERE AT FOX AND
OF COURSE, THE SAD NEWS,
CHARLES KRAUTHAMMER, BELOVED
COLUMNIST, FATHER, HUSBAND, OF
COURSE, CONTRIBUTED A FOX NEWS,
PULITZER PRIZE WINNER, POLITICAL
COMMENTATOR DIED TODAY AT AGE
68.
HIS DEATH WAS A SHOCK BUT WAS
NOT UNEXPECTED.
HE TOLD US TWO WEEKS AGO THAT HE
HAD TERMINAL CANCER AND NOT TOO
LONG TO LIVE.
CHARLES BECAME A
LARGER-THAN-LIFE FIGURE DURING
HIS DECADE AT FOX NEWS.
HE WAS ONE OF THE MOST RESPECTED
POLITICAL ANALYSTS IN
WASHINGTON, I THINK IN THE
UNITED STATES, NO DOUBT ABOUT
IT, AND A BELOVED PRESENCE IN
THE NEWSROOM HERE.
CHARLES WAS ULTIMATELY LOST FOR
WORDS BUT HE OFTEN PUT OTHERS IN
THAT POSITION, AS I KNOW
PERSONALLY.
IT WAS HIS HUMOR, I THINK, THAT
A LOT OF US, AS WE SMILED
TONIGHT REMEMBERING HIM, OR
THINKING ABOUT TONIGHT.
>> ALL KINDS OF FOLKS, FOR THE
LAST YEAR, AND THE END,
HILLARY'S NOT GOING TO RUN.
I SAID 100%, SHE WOULD RUN,
UNLESS SHE IS STRUCK BY
LIGHTNING.
THERE IS NO LIGHTNING.
I THINK THERE IS SOME PEOPLE WHO
GET IN, AND THEY ARE NOT GOING
TO GET OUT UNLESS THEY ARE
BEATEN.
SPEAKING AS AN AMATEUR
PSYCHIATRIST.
SO WHAT IF YOU LOOK LIKE A LUCKY
LUCIANO?
IT DOESN'T MATTER TO US AT ALL.
>> THAT IS DRAWN FOR ME.
[LAUGHTER]
>> I THINK HE WAS CALLING ME.
>> HE WAS DEFINITELY CALLING
YOU.
>> WHAT IS THE DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN A DEMOCRAT AND A
SOCIALIST?
>> A DEMOCRAT IS A SOCIALIST --
>> ARE WE GOING TO FIGHT LIKE
THEY DID?
>> NO, NO.
>> I SAID HERE A WEEK AGO THAT
IT WILL SNOW AND     IN HELL BEF
IT WILL SNOW AND     IN HELL BER
IT WILL SNOW AND     IN HELL BE
IT WILL SNOW AND     IN HELL BEH
IT WILL SNOW AND     IN HELL BEE
OBAMA DOJ INDICTS HILLARY.
I'M WILLING TO ENTERTAIN A
BELIEF IN CLIMATE CHANGE BEFORE
THAT.
>> Laura: MUST BRING IN OUR
DISTINGUISHED PANEL
DISCUSSES LIFE AND CAREER.
ON THE PHONE WITH US,
"SPECIAL REPORT" ANCHOR,
BRET BAIER.
IN THE STUDIO, FOX NEWS SENIOR
POLITICAL ANALYST BRIT HUME,
ASSOCIATE EDITOR AND COLUMNIST
AT REALCLEARPOLITICS,
A.B. STODDARD, AND FOX NEWS
CONTRIBUTOR CHARLIE HURT,
OPINION EDITOR FOR
"THE WASHINGTON TIMES."
BOY, ALL OF US HAVE SO MANY
MEMORIES OF CHARLES.
BEFORE WE GO TO THE PANEL HERE,
BRET, YOU SAT IN THE SEAT SO
MANY NIGHTS, AS DID BRIT HUME,
WITH CHARLES TO YOUR RIGHT, AND
IT WAS ALWAYS A ROLLICKING RIDE.
AND COMMERCIAL BREAKS, WHERE ALL
THE FUN USUALLY HAPPENS, AND IN
THE ONLINE SPECIAL SHOW, WHERE
CHARLES WAS EVEN FUNNIER THAT HE
WAS ON THE PANEL.
SOME REFLECTIONS TONIGHT?
>> YEAH, YOU KNOW, IT IS A
BITTERSWEET MOMENT BECAUSE I
LIKE LOOKING BACK AT THOSE
MOMENTS, AND THE FUN AND HUMOR.
I JUST TALKED TO DANIEL, WHO WAS
AT HIS DAD'S SIDE, ALONG WITH
HIS WIFE, ROBYN, AND THEY'VE
BEEN HEARTENED BY SOME OF THESE
MEMORIES AND SOME OF THE
STORIES, AND LOOKING AT THEIR
DAD AND HIS PRIME, CHARLES COULD
LIGHT UP A ROOM.
HE COULD CRACK A JOKE.
HE WAS MY FIRST BASEMAN THEY ARE
ON THE PANEL FOR ALMOST TEN
YEARS.
BEFORE THAT, ALONGSIDE BRIT HUME
BEFORE THAT, ALONGSIDE BRIT HUM
BRIT HUME.
HE COULD CUT THROUGH THE NOISE
OF THE DAY, AND THEN CRACK US UP
IN THE COMMERCIAL BREAKS LIKE
NOBODY ELSE COULD.
SO HE JUST HAD A GIFT.
HIS WRITING WAS ON LIKE -- I
DON'T THINK YOU ARE GOING TO SEE
ANOTHER COLUMNIST THAT HAD HIS
PENETRATING KIND OF WISDOM AND
THOUGHTS AND WE ARE GOING TO TRY
TO USE THAT AS WE GO ON, BECAUSE
HE'S COMMENTED ON EVERY ISSUE ON
THE DAY.
AND WE'LL BRING HIM INTO THE
CONVERSATION AS WE GO FORWARD.
>> Laura: BRIT HUME.
>> WE'VE KNOWN THIS WAS COMING
FOR SOME WEEKS NOW.
IT BARELY LESSENS THE SADNESS OF
THIS MOMENT.
BUT WHAT THAT MEANS IS, CHARLES
HAD A CHANCE, IN THE LAST FEW
WEEKS OF HIS LIFE, TO HEAR HOW
WE ALL FELT ABOUT HIM.
THE KIND OF TRIBUTE YOU JUST
HEARD FROM BRET, WHAT THE REST
OF US HAVE BEEN SAYING ALL DAY,
IT WASN'T THAT HE WAS JUST SO
BRILLIANT, ALTHOUGH HE WAS, HE
WAS ALSO SO VERY KIND AND FUNNY,
AND WE LOVED HIM.
ALL OF US AROUND HERE LOVED HIM.
THOSE OF US WHO MIGHT BE
CONSIDERED BIG SHOTS LOVED HIM,
EVERYBODY IS LOVE HIM, AS WELL.
I HOPE YOU KNEW THAT, I SUSPECT
HE DID, AND I'M GLAD HE DID FOR
THAT.
>> Laura: EVERYONE FROM THE
MAKEUP ARTISTS, THE GUYS BEHIND
THE CAMERA WHO DO SUCH GOOD
WORK, AND WOMEN BEHIND THE
SCENES, EVERYONE KNEW HIM.
HE DIDN'T WANT TO BE TREATED
DIFFERENTLY, THOUGH, THAN ANYONE
ELSE.
YOU POINTED THAT OUT.
>> YOU ARE TALKING ABOUT THE
BRAKES, BACK IN THE DAY,
"SPECIAL REPORT, CHARLES WAS ON,
HE WOULD COME IN EARLIER BECAUSE
OF THE WHEELCHAIR, IT TOOK HIM
EARLIER TO GET INTO POSITION,
WHICH MEANT THAT THEY WERE TWO
COMMERCIAL BREAKS BEFORE THE
TIME, THAT I GOT TO SPEND WITH
CHARLES.
EVERY NOW AND THEN, HE WOULD
SAY, A KIND WORD TO ME ABOUT MY
WORK.
I ALWAYS FELT LIKE THE EARTH AND
EVERYTHING THAT WAS AND IT HAD
JUST BEEN CONFERRED UPON ME WHEN
I GOT A COMPLIMENT FROM
CHARLES KRAUTHAMMER.
>> Laura: A.B., THERE WAS A
MOMENT ON "THE DAILY SHOW" THAT
I HAD NOT SEEN UNTIL JUST BEFORE
THIS SHOW TONIGHT.
I WOULD LIKE YOUR REACTION AND
THOUGHTS.
LET'S WATCH.
>> 30 YEARS.
DO YOU EVER LOOK BACK ON SOME OF
THESE WRITINGS AND THINK, WHAT
WAS I THINKING?
>> IT'S WORSE THAN THAT.
[LAUGHTER]
>> >> GOOD FOR YOU TO SPEAK OFT
>> >> GOOD FOR YOU TO SPEAK OFE
WORST PART OF WRITING THE BOOK
WAS GOING ALL THE WAY BACK AND
READING THE MILLION WORDS I'VE
WRITTEN, COULDN'T BELIEVE I HAD
WRITTEN SOME OF THAT STUFF.
>> WHAT HAS THE GROWTH PROCESS
BEEN LIKE?
>> THE GROWTH PROCESS, WELL, I
WAS ONCE A LIBERAL.
>> SO THE EARLY WRITINGS SHOWED
HOPE.
>> AND THEN CAME CHANGE.
[LAUGHTER]
>> Laura: I MEAN, A.B., YOU
SAT NEXT TO HIM ON SO MANY
EVENINGS.
>> JUST BRILLIANT.
I WROTE ABOUT HIM LAST WEEKEND I
SAID THAT THE ONLY DEBATE THAT I
EVER WON IN NINE YEARS WAS ON
THE SUPER COMMITTEE, WHICH WAS A
DEBT CUTTING COMMITTEE, WHICH
FELL FLAT ON ITS FACE, HE WROTE
WITH GREAT HOPE ABOUT HOW IT ALL
MIGHT WORK OUT.
IT WAS REALLY GOING TO BE A
GREAT OPPORTUNITY.
WHEN I BUSTED HIM ABOUT IT, WHEN
IT FOLDED, HE SAID THAT WAS ONE
OF THE TIMES WHERE I WASN'T
CYNICAL ENOUGH.
HE WAS NEVER WRONG.
HIS PREDICTION DIDN'T COME TRUE.
USUALLY BECAUSE HE HASN'T BEEN
CYNICAL ENOUGH.
BUT FOR SOMEONE WHO WAS SO
CYNICAL, HE WAS ALSO ALWAYS FULL
OF HOPE AND JOY.
AND HE REALLY DELIGHTED IN THE
LITTLE THINGS, AND THAT WAS AN
INCREDIBLE COMBINATION, SO
STOIC, SO STRONG, BECAUSE OF HIS
BATTLE, AND WHAT HE HAD TO
SURMOUNT IN THE WAKE OF IT.
BUT THEN, JUST AS SOMEONE WHO
REALLY DELIGHTED IN THE WARMTH
AND EXCHANGE OF PEOPLE.
HE LOVED PEOPLE.
WE HAD A NIGHT RIGHT HERE AT THE
TABLE, I'LL NEVER FORGET, EARLY
ON WHEN I DIDN'T KNOW HIM WELL,
AND I WAS SEATED IN BETWEEN HIM
AND STEVE AND BRET ARE MAKING
SOME COLLEGE OVER DRINKING
JOKES, AND CHARLES SAID, THAT
COMMERCIAL ALWAYS SAYS TO ME,
THE ONLY BEER TO HAVE WHEN YOU
ARE HAVING MORE THAN ONE.
THEN HE PAUSED PERFECTLY TIMED,
MORE THAN ONE WHAT?
AND THEN OF COURSE, IT WAS RIGHT
BACK TO THE PANEL, AND WE WERE
BACK ON CAMERA, AND I WAS
PRACTICALLY UNDER THE TABLE.
HIS COMEDIC TIMING WAS
UNBELIEVABLE.
ALSO, SOMETIMES, JUST HAD THE
DELIGHT OF A SMALL KID.
IT WAS REALLY SOMETHING TO
BEHOLD.
>> Laura: PSYCHIATRIST,
HARVARD MEDICAL SCHOOL, PULITZER
PRIZE, MORE AWARDS THAN WE CAN
LIST HERE.
BUT CHARLES, WHEN HE WROTE ABOUT
A POLITICAL MOVEMENT OR EVENT,
HE WROTE ABOUT IT IN A WAY THAT
HE CUT THROUGH WHERE SO MANY
OTHERS WERE MIRED IN MINUTIA.
PRESIDENT REAGAN, I LOVED THIS
PART, OF COURSE THIS WAS AFTER
REAGAN'S DEATH.
HE WROTE, "OPTIMISM IS OF THE
PERFECT WAY TO TRIVIALIZE
EVERYTHING THAT REAGAN WAS
ORDERED.
OPTIMISM, EVERY OTHER PERSON ON
THE NUMBER SIX BUS IS AN
OPTIMIST.
WHAT DISTINGUISHED REAGAN WAS
WHAT HE DID AND SAID.
REAGAN WAS OPTIMISTIC ABOUT
AMERICA BY THE CYNICISM AND
GENERAL RETREAT OF    OF THE
POST-VIETNAM ERA BECAUSE HE
BELIEVED ON FASHIONABLY THAT
AMERICA WAS BOTH GREAT AND
GOOD."
I LOVE THAT.
LIKE AN OLD UNCLE, REAGAN IS SO
OPTIMISTIC, BUT IT WAS
OPTIMISTIC ABOUT THE GOODNESS OF
AMERICA.
I LOVE THE FACT THAT HE POINTED
THAT OUT.
HE WAS ALWAYS CUTTING AGAINST
THE CONVENTIONAL WISDOM.
>> THAT AND OF ITSELF IS THE
OPTIMISTIC VIEW OF AMERICA.
OF COURSE, I HAVE THE PLEASURE
OF KNOWING CHARLES FAR LESS THAN
ANYBODY SITTING AT THIS TABLE,
BUT I REMEMBER BEING A YOUNGER
BOY, GROWING UP IN A SMALL TOWN,
AND WE GOT
"THE WASHINGTON POST," AND I
REMEMBER MY FATHER WOULD RIP OUT
HIS COLUMNS AND SEND THEM TO ME,
GIVE THEM TO ME, AND THAT HAD A
PROFOUND IMPACT ON MY INTEREST
IN NEWSPAPERS, AND OBVIOUSLY
POLITICS.
HE WAS OBVIOUSLY BRILLIANT,
FUNNY, ALL OF THESE THINGS PRAY
THAT THE TITLE OF HIS BOOK,
"THINGS THAT MATTER," WAS THE
MOST PERFECT TITLE OF A BOOK FOR
HIM, BECAUSE WHAT HE DID BETTER
THAN ANYTHING ELSE WAS TO CUT
THROUGH ALL THE NOISE AND PUT
EVERYTHING INTO PERSPECTIVE,
WITH THE THINGS THAT WERE
IMPORTANT, AND THE THINGS THAT
MATTERED.
>> THAT BOOK WAS A COLLECTION.
COLLECTIONS DON'T SELL.
>> Laura: IT WAS ON THE
BEST SELLER LIST FOR A YEAR AND
A HALF.
>> THAT SOLD LIKE HOT CAKES FOR
YEARS.
I THINK PEOPLE ARE STILL BUYING
IT.
I GOT A COPY OF IT.
>> I WAS ON THE TRAIN COMING
FROM NEW YORK YESTERDAY, THERE
WAS A GUY SITTING THERE READING
THAT BOOK.
>> Laura: I WANT TO MENTION
BRET'S SPECIAL, PEOPLE HAVE TO
TAKE THAT HOUR AND SIT DOWN, IT
IS ABSOLUTELY BREATHTAKING.
TOMORROW NIGHT, 9:00 P.M. ON
FOX NEWS, I CAN'T WAIT TO WATCH
IT.
I'VE SEEN BITS AND PIECES, BUT I
HAVEN'T SEEN THE WHOLE THING.
BRET, THE NIGHT AFTER NIGHT
AFTER NIGHT, ELECTION NIGHT,
PRIMARY NIGHT, KRAUTHAMMER WAS
TOUGH ON THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN BUT
ALSO VERY FAIR.
HE AND I GOT INTO SOME LEGENDARY
BATTLES ON THE PANEL IN THE
RUN-UP TO THE ELECTION, WITH
GEORGE WILL, HIS BEST FRIEND,
AND IT WAS A SPIRITED DEBATE,
WAS ALWAYS SO MUCH FUN, THERE.
HE WAS SUCH A GREAT SPARRING
PARTNER ON THE ISSUE OF RISING
POPULISM VERSUS THE OLD BUSH
GLOBALISM, INTERVENTIONISM.
HE LOVED THE PHILOSOPHICAL BACK
AND FORTH THAT I THINK MAKES
"SPECIAL REPORT" SUCH AN
IMPORTANT SHOW TO HAVE FEATURED
HIM.
I KNOW BRIT HUME WAS THE FIRST
ONE TO REALLY PUT HIM ON THE
SHOW, AND THAT MADE THE
DIFFERENCE ON THAT PANEL.
HE REALLY -- I KNOW YOU'VE
MISSED HIM SINCE, WE'VE ALL
MISSED HIM HERE AT FOX.
>> YEAH.
HE REALLY WAS A POWERHOUSE.
HE LOVED GETTING INTO THE
POLITICS.
HE LOVED ENGAGING WITH YOU AND
TUCKER AND OTHERS ON THE ISSUES
OF THE DAY POLITICALLY
OF THE DAY POLITICALLY         P
OF THE DAY POLITICALLY         L
OF THE DAY POLITICALLY         T
OF THE DAY POLITICALLY         C
OF THE DAY POLITICALLY         L
OF THE DAY POLITICALLY         I
OF THE DAY POLITICALLY         E
OF THE DAY POLITICALLY         .
I TRIED TO GET PANELISTS TO PUT
CHIPS AND BETS ON POTENTIAL
CANDIDATES.
WE HAD 17 IN THE BEGINNING OF
THIS PROCESS, REPUBLICANS.
SO HE DID NOT PUT ANY MONEY ON
TRUMP AND EVENTUALLY, HE WAS
BEGRUDGINGLY PUTTING FIVE AND
TEN, AND HE WAS     WOULD ALWAYS
TEN, AND HE WAS     WOULD ALWAYP
TEN, AND HE WAS     WOULD ALWAYT
TEN, AND HE WAS     WOULD ALWAYA
FIVE CHIP ON ONE WOMEN IN ZONE,
AND HE JUST HAD A GREAT TIME
WITH IT.
HE WAS SOMEBODY WHO I THINK
TOUCHED PEOPLE IN A WAY THAT,
EVEN IF YOU DIDN'T AGREE WITH
HIM, YOU KIND OF NODDED YOUR
HEAD AND SAID, ALL RIGHT, I GET
THAT.
>> Laura: BRIT, TRUMP, WE
THINK ABOUT WHAT IS HAPPENING
WITH THE BIG IMMIGRATION DEBATE,
SEPARATING THE FAMILIES, I JUST
WANT TO KNOW WHAT KRAUTHAMMER
WOULD BE SAYING.
>> ME, TOO.
>> Laura: WHAT WOULD HE SAY
ABOUT THE NAZI CONCENTRATION
CAMP ISSUE?
>> HE WAS OFFENDED BY TRUMP.
IN ANY WAY.
>> Laura: LET'S BE HONEST, HE
THOUGHT, AS DOES GEORGE WILL,
TRUMP IS A HORRIBLE BULGARIAN.
HE DID BELIEVE THAT.
LET'S BE HONEST.
>> HE THOUGHT HE WAS IGNORANT
AND ADVANTAGEOUS.
>> Laura: NO LOVE LOST.
>> ONCE TRUMP WAS NOMINATED AND
BECAME PRESIDENT, I THINK
CHARLES, LIKE SOME OF THE REST
OF US, WAS DEEPLY OFFENDED BY
THE COVERAGE OF HIM.
HE WAS VERY FAIR TO TRUMP DURING
THE COURSE OF HIS PRESIDENCY,
FOR AS LONG AS CHARLES WAS ABLE
TO WITNESS IT, A YEAR BEFORE WE
LOST THEM TO THIS TERRIBLE
ILLNESS.
>> Laura: HE HAD A COLUMN IN
2011, A.B., CALLED "ALONE IN THE
UNIVERSE," ONE OF THE COLUMNS,
USING THE TITLE, YOU GOT TO READ
IT.
I WENT BACK AND READ IT TODAY.
TALKING ABOUT HOW MANY GALAXIES,
CONSTELLATIONS, LIFE ON OTHER
PLANETS AND SO FORTH.
HE SAID AT THE END, "WE GROW
JUSTLY WEARY OF OUR POLITICS BUT
WE MUST OR MEMBER THIS.
POLITICS, AND ALEX GRUBBY,
GRASPING, CORRUPT, CONTEMPTIBLE
MANIFESTATIONS, IS SOVEREIGN
IN HUMAN AFFAIRS.
EVERYTHING ULTIMATELY RESTS UPON
IT, FAIRLY OR NOT, POLITICS IS
THE DRIVER OF HISTORY."
I THINK I WOULD DEBATE HIM ON
THAT BECAUSE I DON'T KNOW IF
POLITICS IS THAT IMPORTANT TO
MOST PEOPLE'S LIVES.
BUT IT WAS IMPORTANT TO HIM AND
HE THOUGHT THE DEBATES THAT WE
WERE HAVING, OF COURSE THAT WAS
2011, DURING THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION, ALL THE BIG
QUESTIONS ABOUT HOW WE HANDLE
TERROR AND OTHER COUNTRIES,
FOREIGN AFFAIRS, WERE VERY
IMPORTANT.
BUT HE ALWAYS HAD A VERY
INTERESTING CLINICAL TAKE TO MY
PSYCHIATRIST TAKE ON THE
AFTERLIFE, WHETHER THERE WAS AN
AFTERLIFE.
I JUST WONDER, LIKE, I JUST WANT
TO HAVE A CONVERSATION ABOUT
THIS.
WHEN I READ THIS, I WAS LIKE,
THIS IS WHY I LOVED BEING ON
WITH KRAUTHAMMER.
>> WE ALL DO.
THAT WAS WHAT IT WAS A WONDERFUL
ABOUT HIS COLUMNS, THEY WOULD GO
OFF ON ALL THESE OTHER HUGE --
>> Laura: BEING A FATHER.
>> THE PERSPECTIVE WAS SO BROAD.
THE THING ABOUT HOW MUCH HE
LOVED POLITICS AND BELIEVED IT
WAS AN IMPORTANT DEBATE, AND THE
DISCOURSE WAS SO IMPORTANT, EVEN
THOUGH IT'S ERODED AND DEGRADED
SO RAPIDLY, HE REALLY BELIEVED
THAT EVERYONE SHOULD BE
PERSUADABLE, AT LEAST AROUND THE
EDGES.
HE DIDN'T LIKE PEOPLE WHO
WEREN'T WILLING TO JUST BE
PERSUADED A BIT HERE AND THERE.
AND SO HE TRIED TO BRING THAT TO
HIS ARGUMENT.
MOST OF THE TIME IT WORKS ON
PEOPLE.
THEY WOULD SAY, EVEN IF I DIDN'T
AGREE AT THE END, I REALLY SAW
HOW WELL HE MADE THE POINT.
SO HE ENGAGED THEM.
AND THAT WAS AN ART OF
PERSUASION AND ITSELF.
>> Laura: CHARLIE, YOU WORKED
IN A LOT OF COLUMNS IN YOUR DAY,
ON BEING A COLUMNIST, HE WROTE,
"LONGEVITY FOR A COLUMNIST IS A
SIMPLE PROPOSITION, ONCE YOU
START, YOU DON'T STOP.
YOU DO IT UNTIL YOU DIE OR CAN
NO LONGER PUT A SENTENCE
TOGETHER.
IT HAS ALWAYS BEEN MY INTENTION
TO DIE AT MY DESK, ALTHOUGH MY
MOST CHERISHED AMBITION IS TO
OUTLIVE THE ESTATE TAX."
WELL, HE ALMOST DID.
WE'VE DOUBLED THE ESTATE
EXEMPTION, SO HE DID PRETTY WELL
ON THAT.
AGAIN, HUMOR IN THE FACE OF
DIFFICULTY, AND I DON'T KNOW.
THAT WAS JUST ANOTHER.
>> I THINK HE WOULD AGREE WITH
YOU IN TERMS OF POLITICS IS NOT
WHAT EVERYTHING IS ABOUT.
HE IS RIGHT, POLITICS IS ABOUT
POWER, WHO CAN GOVERN, IN THAT
RESPECT, IT IS THE MOST
IMPORTANT THING BECAUSE IT IS
HOW WE DETERMINE WHAT RIGHTS WE
HAVE.
AT THE END OF THE DAY, HE WANTED
TO GO TO A BASEBALL GAME.
HE WOULD HAVE LOVED TO HAVE BEEN
AT THE GAME TONIGHT, HE WOULD
HAVE BEEN EMBARRASSED BY THAT.
BUT HE WOULD HAVE LOVED TO HAVE
BEEN THERE.
I DON'T KNOW ANYBODY WHO
SQUEEZED MORE OUT OF LIFE THAN
DR. KRAUTHAMMER.
>> Laura: GUYS, THANK YOU SO
MUCH TONIGHT.